let's get to our big Jada pinkett-smith
exclusive on tomorrow's episode of red
tabletalk they focus on addiction which
is a major concern at a time like this
where so many people are in isolation
but during the conversation Jada learned
a shocking truth about her mother's past
struggles we only shoot when we feel
like it's something that's needed you
know and this particular show it was a
show that was was needed
here's the thing that shocked me
this morning was when you said you
overdosed a few times overdosed a few
times that's part of being a drug addict
of course she wasn't trying to get clean
during a pandemic but she just has some
really veteran useful tips in regards to
how to stay clean how to stay connected
how was it as a daughter and then
looking at your daughter digesting that
information I think she actually really
enjoys hearing those stories in here and
what we've been through because she gets
to see who we are on the other side
willow has some of reveals of her own
during that episode I won't get into
that babe yes did it scare you as a
mother
oh no it's a journey that I knew about I
was just read Table Talk is shot inside
Will and Jada is home cameras are locked
down and it's produced remotely they'd
film three Kovan 19 focus episodes since
dismissed went under self quarantine
Jada you guys will continue shooting
throughout this whole thing and you just
did the coal bit special what was the
response you got from that special a lot
that I heard was hey you know I'm I'm
less scared we'll came on and and we got
a specialist there has never been a time
in human history where human beings were
not in a tug of war battle with viruses
and I have to give him props I thought
dr. will was good yeah doctor will
[Music]